[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
there is that for to think of a future
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
and my brother John we answer your
questions if you'd abuse it by sending
you all the week's news from both Mars
and AFC Wimbledon how are you John I'm
terrible my family is covered in flu we
got our flu vaccines we were responsible
citizens and we got the flu vaccine but
it has failed it has failed and my child
one of my children threw up on me last
night and it's I had a very long night
also it's partly the fault of the
throwing up on me and like I thought
honestly at this point I thought maybe
we were past the era of my children
vomiting on me and so that's a bit of a
bummer because I feel like it's just
regression and also I stayed up way way
too late last night in addition to the
sick child thing I was listening to the
new podcast s town are you familiar with
this huh oh my god it's incredible
it is the the the podcast from the
makers of serial I feel like I should
know but there's so many podcasts John
and there's so many good ones why does
anyone listen to ours I don't know but
this podcast s town is more like a
Faulkner novel than it is like dear Hank
and John it is closer to Nobel Prize
territory whereas we are closer to you
know Darwin prize territory so yeah how
are you I'm good I'm good I I know that
s town is a big deal you know how I know
is because I've started to see hot ticks
about it people who are like s town is a
great podcast that should never have
been made and I'm like oh yeah there we
are there we are straight up in the
cultural relevancy of today that's what
happens when you get famous enough
everybody starts to tell you how great
you are while also telling you you
shouldn't exist it is I mean it is kind
of true that if you make it even for a
little bit to the white-hot center of
American popular culture it's sort of a
terrible experience because oh yeah
people oh yeah they just hate
you like they go from they go from
liking the stuff that you made to just
thinking it's terrible
I thought s town was great and I don't
care that it's popular III have stopped
being one of these people who says like
I only liked Nirvana's early work like
uh I just want to like stuff it's so
it's so hard to find anything in this
world that you can just you can just
love and I love des town I thought it
was fantastic and weird and great and
I'm yeah I'm also very tired because of
this flu issue would you like a short
poem yeah okay all right this is from
Dorothy Parker once when I was young and
true someone left me sad broke my
brittle heart and - and that's very bad
love is for unlucky folk love is but a
curse once there was a heart I broke and
that I think is worse Oh Dorothy Parker
yeah how to twist the knife in that last
line that's what short poems should be
John I'm all for that I understand what
Dorothy Parker's talking about I so
rarely understand what a poet is talking
about or I'm not quite sure well just
maybe the point but I just want to know
just tell me what you mean I'm sorry
it's been a while since I've complained
about short poems or poetry in general
on the pod because you know that gets
old but but I just wanted to thank
through the parker for doing it the way
that works for me individually Dear John
and Hank my biggest claim to fame is now
and probably forever will be that when
you google image search a certain
chicken breed quail antwerp Belgian
Bantam for reference I am the first non
chicken to show up I'm obviously pretty
proud of this but my question is how do
I casually work this into conversations
pumpkins and quail Antwerp Belgium
bantams Lauren well if I think I've hit
myself onto a picture of Lauren here and
les Lauren was lying and and I assume
that she's this person holding the
chickens and not the chickens themselves
cuz she said that she was a non chicken
right well she actually says in the
question Hank just to be clear that
she's the first non chicken result and I
have also found a picture of Lauren this
is fantastic
look at all the prizes that
successful chickens amazing I mean I
don't blame her for wanting to to share
this news yeah so I guess the way that I
would do it is whenever somebody asks so
what do you do just judging from your
picture Lauren I think that you're
probably a student so I would I wouldn't
but I wouldn't say I'm a student I would
say I raise quail Antwerp Belgian Bantam
chickens and I'm actually the leading
human in the feed like like according to
Google I am the leading here I'm the
lead
yeah human John right now I'm scrolling
through the results for Hank green to
find out who the first non Hank green
person is who comes up and you'd think I
was assuming I liked it it wasn't gonna
be interesting so it wasn't even gonna
mention it that it would be you right I
would have thought it would be me - it's
not who is it it is uh it is Ashley
Clements in the first episode of the
Lizzie Bennet diaries well I think
that's great she's much cooler and more
interesting than I am
can we get back to this quail antwort
Belgian Bantam chicken thing because
actually what I find most amazing is
that if you scroll through all the
Google image search results literally
thousands of them you don't come across
any other humans
Lauro is the only human in the quail
antwerp belgium Bantam chicken world
well you don't even see a human hand
there's yeah this is all Briggs this is
the longest I have scrolled seeing
nothing but chickens in my there some
eggs there's some eggs there's some
chicks and there's also a number of non
non chickens there's some quails which
is not what we were looking for but you
know not not humans I see a horse and a
cat's awesome I saw some people's feet
this is a great bit no wonder that we're
being compared to s towns some people
said that this is the S town of advice
podcast Lauren you just need to get a
t-shirt and say I would just print the
picture on the t-shirt actually because
then people will ask you about your
t-shirt and you can just say listen
right as it happens on the leading
quayle Antwerp Belgium Bantam you know
human being you on Google well sometimes
I think I get
best to have those things in your back
pocket for not leading with like like if
I was if I had been and I kid like for
for example I I've done some cool stuff
and I don't I don't tend to like start
off with like my supreme achievement I
start I start off with like and then I
let but at work in and people are like
oh that's a neat thing but you're not
totally like you haven't let that seep
into you so much that it's like all
about who you are you have this cool
thing about yourself that that comes up
later in the conversation and then
people think it's cooler so like what
you hold back is that in 1998 Winter
Park High School voted you best dancer
right like you can't lead with that but
but right when when it comes up and then
it's like oh he's he knows this about
himself but he's not he's not like
putting it on his t-shirt though I do
kind of want to put it on my t-shirt now
that I said that I think what you need
is a lot of chicken trivia like you need
you mean more than just this you can
just sort of like you know this is
clearly it's become a big part of your
persona so you just have to run with it
lean in and say hey like did you know
that there are more chickens in America
than humans and and etc is that true yes
but that's like the only chicken trivia
I have Lauren so you're gonna have to
work on the rest of it yourself John
I've got another question all right give
it to me
dear Hank and John not thought I want to
bore you with even more questions about
rich people but something that's been
gnawing at my mind lately why do rich
people like golf so much what is it
about golf that appeals to them over all
other sports for Isaac Lawton Hank do
you know that a chicken's body
temperature normally runs between 100 to
130 degrees Fahrenheit so chicken
essentially always has a human fever so
if you surrounded yourself with chickens
you be you be like toasty like too hot
yeah it's almost like be like going in a
hot tub yeah it's like a bat that's like
bath temperature so you could you heat a
bath with a chicken or enough jugs it's
something I never want to find out go
back to the question I Isaac just simply
ends his question for Isaac
so do rich people do you said do you
yell for is that a thing is it or is
that like a just a trope that like
beaming up Scotty
yeah Hank I have no idea like I know
people who play golf okay my best friend
plays a ton of golf but I don't know
anything about it
my theory is well okay III don't know is
the short answer
okay me yeah because I'd start I used to
bowl a lot Hank as you know like I used
to blow every day for several hours a
day it was like uh for about a year it
was a really intense fascination of mine
and what I loved about bowling is that
you're essentially trying to do the
exact same thing over and over and over
again but it's impossible to do over and
over and over again like you can't write
you can't quite do the right thing every
time and that's just fascinating it's
pretty amazing yeah yeah Golf has a
little bit of that element but then you
always have to do other things because
you have to change clubs and sometimes
you're putting it just seems to me like
a nice walk well I think there's a John
Feinstein book called a good walk
spoiled and it's always seem that way to
me like why don't you just walk nine
miles with your friends
yeah I mean it is it's a thing that you
can do while you're having a meeting and
like you can like like it's a way of
like I've I also never golf to be clear
this is a guess it's it like it's a way
of having a social experience with
people who are colleagues and like
mediated through this activity that then
but like there's lots of time for
talking about of forgetting to know each
other but then you like you have this
great opportunity where 90% of the time
can be getting to know each other and
then 10% the time can be actually like
so so how much is the minimum order
quantity for your your your manufactured
product colleague business person right
but I think ever
bowling is the same way like that to me
you could do that with could be yeah any
any sort of like chess sport basic
we don't know it's one of the great
mysteries of the human species why all
rich people are drawn to golf like moths
to the flame it's also a very expensive
sport so maybe it's a way of yeah it's
more um like establishing a sort of
class system I don't know I don't know
either it's become it's I think it's
become a little bit of less of an
expensive sport but like it's designed
to take up a bunch of space like you
can't play golf without a lot of space
and the more space you have the better
your golf is so I think there's a
certain amount of it this is something
that is not accessible to other folk and
so it is appealing in that way and I
don't think that's I don't think that's
conscious but there may be some kind of
subconscious thing there I don't want to
move on from the question too soon Hank
but I would argue that we're actually
moving on from it too late did you know
that chicken sperm can survive in it in
a hen for up to 32 days whoa that is
distressing to me that there's something
like that upsets the germaphobe part of
me Hank I have another question it comes
from Cornelia who asks Dear John and
Hank since people are for some reason
planning on going to Mars it got me
thinking what color is the sky on Mars
the picture I have in my head is that it
looks just like the night sky with the
exception of one giant star instead of
very many small ones is that true
surely it's not the same color blue that
we have here on earth because of the
differences in our atmosphere or
something I love that or something it's
just perfect yeah I I couldn't agree
with you more Cornelia Hank or something
ah yeah it's different color it's weird
it's weird so you'd think that we would
know the answer to this question you can
see if we know the answer to this one
John we you would and we kinda do we
kind of do but we kind of don't cuz look
at your sky what color is the sky on
earth it's a bunch of different colors
sometimes it's black sometimes it's blue
sometimes it's a dark blue or a light
blue or like a purple or an orange the
sky is a bunch of different colors and
it is the same way on Mars but even
weirder and more confusing making than
that you've seen like the dress right
and everybody's like it's yellow and
gold or white and gold or blue and black
our brains when we see like they like we
have like a sort of auto white balance
system in our brains so that when we
look at like a color it doesn't like a
different color depending on like where
the light is hitting it and so we can we
know like that's red and like that
entire tablecloth is red despite the
fact that like one side of it isn't
doesn't have as much light on it and the
other side has more light on it and
there's lots of wrinkles and so like you
know though that the whole thing is red
and so there is some speculation and and
when we take pictures of Mars we kind of
have to guess what our eyes would see
and sometimes we balance it more to what
like what it would look like if it were
on earth with Earth's atmosphere and
sometimes we balance it more to like
what we think we would see but at the
same time there's there's this like
unknown quantity to what the sky on Mars
looks like that we will not really know
until we have a human there to look at
it so I'm not a scientist but just quick
question couldn't you know you got that
minivan on Mars right now uh-huh
what if you just turned that little mofo
up had it look up at the sky and took a
picture I mean we've done this but they
already thought oh yeah the thing is you
have to you have to white balance it you
have to like decide like what white is
on I mean did we not get a good camera
up there but like sorry shoes what white
is just like when when I take a picture
with my camera I get to choose what
white is they have to choose what white
is that it's not entirely clear what
white would be for a person who is
standing on the surface of Mars with a
very different with very different
sunlight and with very different
atmospheric composition now we we have a
pretty good idea I've set all of this
now and I can say that like if you were
on the surface of Mars you would look up
and on the majority of days at like at
like not sunset or sunrise you would see
something like a sort of brownie like a
like a brownie orange even like like a
like even sometimes maybe kind of a
yellowish color but but there are also
times too
pending on how much like water like my
son's vomit which water is God how much
water like ice is in this guy that you
would see more of like a bluegray and
they think that like despite the fact
that like the color is more or like a
dark sort of orangey brown you you your
mind might perceive that more as a gray
because your mind is like getting ready
to see a different like it's expecting
colors to be a certain color it's just
it's weird like colors are weird which
we have discovered with the internet
getting really obsessed with address and
hat what colors it is you know what else
is weird
check chickens as the chickens there are
25 billion chickens that means that
chickens are the most successful bird
species on earth have their armored
chickens than there are any other bird
and ever have been that is that is an
impossible number of birds it is that is
nuts are there more of anything then of
chickens uh yeah there's more krill oh
that makes sense
that makes sense I totally buy into the
plankton all that stuff how did you know
that like off the top of your head or is
that in the article you're skeeving from
right now oh no I know all these chicken
facts but even I'm not I had an article
this is just this is just stuff I know
I've got by the way I'm just getting
started
if you thought like oh this was a little
bit of a good bit and it's over no wrong
it's just beginning
Hank do you know where the world chicken
population is the highest what nation
has the most chickens on earth is it the
United States of America no the United
States is second with 1.7 billion
chickens is it China it's China with 3.6
billion chickens are chickens they have
and you know what this is something that
we never talked about like everybody
says oh we need to be worried about our
trade imbalance with cha what about our
chicken imbalance with China I mean this
is this is an issue of national security
we are almost 2 billion chickens behind
gate John
this question comes from anonymous and
not what did I just say who asks this is
a kind of a
and related question John why can't we
see bird ears where are they
great question have you by the way
thanks anonymous for not signing that
one yeah you don't want what's what is
the I totally understand your desire to
remain an unnamed source of this story
birds have ears they are under their
feathers their little holes in the sides
of their heads it's interesting to think
about ears as as like like a functional
thing rather than a physical thing so I
think of an ear and I picture like the
thing that Vincent van Gogh cut off his
head if he actually did that he did and
like it's the it's the cartilage that is
hanging off the side of your head but
functionally an ear is just like the
thing you used to hear with and so for
other animals there is like the thing
that they used to hear with doesn't
actually have external physiology birds
just have like a hole in this side of
their head and I like like reptiles have
those too I don't know what they're
called if there's like a different name
for for ears that don't have ears but
what do you know do you know how many
pounds of chicken the average American
eats in a year it's distressing uh well
I I probably eat I don't know maybe
maybe two to two to five pounds of
chicken a week what so I'm gonna say
wait what you eat five pounds Oh chicken
a week I don't know maybe that's are
easy on a bigger telling me that you
have on average like 10 to 12 chicken
meals per week
ah that's not possible respectfully you
don't I don't agree that you eat five
pounds of chicken a week that's
ludicrous I really like I mean I'm sure
you could in an emergency I'm saying
that in the average week you don't
choose there's three meals a day there
are three meals a day one of them I mean
I guess eggs kinda in a bar and one of
the great questions but I'm just talking
sandwiches and a good chicken night we
actually you know what it's it's eighty
four point nine pounds a year and I'm
moving on to another question even I'm
tired of this bit this question comes
from Shane who writes Dear John and Hank
a friend of mine recently got a tattoo
of a world map on his forearm I don't
really like tattoos in general but
that's not the issue here the main
problem is that the map is a Mercator
projection should I tell him about all
the inaccuracies and problematic
socio-cultural viewpoints associated
with the Mercator projection or would it
be unfair to ruin his forearm for him
forever yours etc Shane uh well first of
all it's on his forearm so he could just
turn it upside down and see it the way
like the way that if the world was the
other way around and so you could see
like right a bit like like hey look it
doesn't have to be North doesn't have to
be the top of the map it could be audio
so you got that going for a belt could
be up I don't think that's really the
issue though I mean I think the
projection just makes countries look the
wrong size you know yes all maps have
their problems but as that is the most
famous map its problems are the most
famous problems yeah obviously Shane the
time to have this conversation with your
friend was like the hour right - thirty
years before the time and I think now is
probably not the time to have the
conversation but John if it comes up at
some point I think you can share your
opinions but I feel like yeah I probably
don't want to start that convo so but so
you said all maps have their problems
yep but the globe a globe is a kind of
map and it does not have that problem in
that like all the things on a globe are
the right shape because the earth is
round you don't have to flatten it out
so like you get a beach ball and you put
a goal put a map on it and you're pretty
good what body parts
well what body part yeah but you don't
have a spherical body part to tattoo a
global you do you got no you don't well
it's close your whole head no that's a
terrible idea on several levels you get
you're gonna have to cut Antarctica
because they you have a neck but
everything
you could pretty like and it's much
better than any flat map projection so
you're gonna like top yeah I mean I
agree it would be better than any flat
map projection but it comes with its own
set of problems you have to like you'd
have to largely I think the biggest
issue is that you would have to shave
your head all of you do that otherwise
you're gonna be like really biased
against one hemisphere or the other and
so that's gonna look like I mean you
want to talk about Eurocentrism if you
choose to put Europe on your forehead
yeah you know I mean that's not as well
what you got to do the other hand like
you got up you know like the Pacific on
your your face so you don't have too
much face tattoo happening because this
I think it's huge
yeah just like well there's a lie it's
like Hawaii maybe like Japan on one
cheek I mean I guess that's a good I
guess that's a good call Hank like it's
a it's an interesting theory I guess my
my biggest concern with it is that
you're probably going to have Australia
on your jawbone no matter what you do
even if you put the Pacific on her face
and then on the other side really your
whole right cheek is going to be the
Americas and I think I feel like that's
gonna look that's gonna look America
centric that's gonna look like you're
privileged in the Americas over
afro-eurasia and in the end like nothing
against the Americas but afro-eurasia
historically is where most of the
actions been the point is that unless
you can spin a map in a globe form it's
very and even then you're putting north
up instead of north down so it's just I
I think it's very hard not to have some
level of bias and I would argue that I I
look I'm all for face tattoos but you
know but I think I don't know if that's
the face tattooed again I'm looking at
pictures of a map tattoos on people's
forearms right now and they're cool what
one this one is pretty good
Greenland isn't too huge Africa looks
substantial I'm in it I'm Haley Hank
yeah are you are you finding yourself
thinking more about getting a tattoo
because I am I
no I am I don't know when that started
but I totally am I mean me neither
I know it's happening and I I don't know
if it's uh I don't know if it's a
midlife crisis thing I I think I'm a
bunch of things that are happening to me
or midlife crisis things so it's totally
possible but or if it's just that like
tattoos have been so normalized that now
I think like maybe I will get a tattoo
but I've made it you know probably about
half my life without one and I feel like
it's also the time when a tattoo would
look best on me is probably Rast a
little bit of that yeah yes I agree with
you I don't know there's so many there's
just so many cool cool tattoos and
people in like I think that the deck the
techniques are getting better like
tattoo yeah they seem to look cooler now
than they used to
yeah they don't all look like Ryan
Gosling's uh yeah I can't yeah yeah this
guy has a bunch of country flags
tattooed on his head in face so that's
great that's something that's good but I
don't see and I haven't found anybody
who's tattooed the the globe on onto
their head and face unfortunately so you
could be the first oh my god I mean
really it's hard to even tell me I
forgot there is an S town yeah
all right this question I mean no wonder
blue apron won't sponsor us we're crap
that's disgusted comes from Natalie who
asked dear Hank and John I recently had
a few teeth removed an operation which
required I be put to sleep
with whatever drug they use for that
sort of thing anyway whatever I was high
on made me cry uncontrollably I didn't
feel sad I just felt the need to cry my
mom claims that my reaction to this drug
lets her know how I'll act when I've had
alcohol I'd say those are two different
types of intoxication as John is very
familiar with dental operations I was
wondering if you would agree Hank I'm
not ignoring you I just don't know if
you've ever been anesthetized high on
life and painkillers Natalie yeah I mean
this is one of my areas of expertise
because I've had a lot of oral surgeries
in which I've been anesthetized in many
different ways
so had a reasonable amount of alcohol in
my life and I would say that your mother
is dead wrong about this I do not think
that when you have two glasses of wine
you will find yourself uncontrollably
weeping no I'm wrong but that's my
suspicion you know there's this thing
about like oh this person's a happy
drunk this person's a sad drunk I don't
I don't know about that man I've
definitely had both definitely been on
both yeah I've definitely experienced
both sides of that coin it's really
about what you bring into the experience
um but I think actually uncontrollable
crying is a pretty common side effect of
some of the yeah yeah it's conscious
sedation stuff that they do for for oral
surgeries these days I offered just to
go with novocaine and maybe if I'm
uncomfortable or scared a little bit of
the laughing gas I don't really I don't
need to go all the way into a twilight
state I like to know what's going on
you know I'll actually like to watch the
little screen where I can see them going
inside my death looking for my secret
root canal that failed or whatever
god I hate history so much I don't want
to I mean I just I'm sorry about your I
just hate it I just I was talking so so
I've been anesthetized recent was from
my colonoscopy where they give you that
sort of like waking sedation and that
the nurse was telling me that that like
a fair number of people get really sad a
fair number people get really happy and
giddy and then there's like a not
insignificant people who become entire
like super belligerent mean and nasty
and like they like they're like yell and
they try to get away and they fight
people and and like that like they have
like tie them down basically and I did I
got super happy the last time to the
point where I was like I could
definitely see myself abusing this drug
don't let me have this don't even tell
me what it's called because this is a
fun thing and I had a real good time and
I didn't remember any of it afterward
but Katherine assures me
I was having it a good good ol good old
high on whatever it yes so they've
stopped using that drug in the last year
Hank I'm also an expert in the field of
colonoscopies and increasingly they use
a different drug that you don't you
don't have the memory loss from but you
also don't have that sweet sweet feeling
of Demerol coursing through your veins
so that's just an update just an update
for you oh well now I now I've no III
used to like but after that experience I
was like well I'm not gonna I've got I'm
looking forward to my next cold recipe
but I guess now not so much please
please steer clear of Demerol it is the
bad path the difficult it's a difficult
path to fall down okay I think we got a
question from Tess who writes to your
green brothers my name is Tess and I'm a
senior in high school you trying to be
the new Ryan tests on the class
president and I'll be expected to give a
speech my graduation ceremony whenever I
sit down to write I just get angry at
myself for not being as eloquent and
profound as I want to be at other times
I listen to podcasts and I'm odd as you
give some of the most profound
statements as easily as one would read a
street sign Tess I believe that you may
have written to the wrong podcast I
think that you are trying to talk to s
town and they do they are doing a great
job do you have any advice on how to be
more profound also what would you say to
a class of 51 graduates hold up I was so
impressed with Tess for being the the
president of the class but it turns out
that yeah like she had like a 2% chance
of being the president of her classes
only 51 people although my class of 52
and I sure as hell wasn't the president
of my class also what would you say to a
class of 51 graduates as they enter a
world that at times seems more
malevolent than benign well that's the
lovely sentiment right there any advice
my wife is appreciated don't let the
bastards get you down Tess you go out
what you gotta say well you got to start
out with like hey I know that it
sometimes seems like the world out there
is more malevolent than benign but I'm
Tess my name is and I'm here to tell you
what John and Hank read told me to tell
you
which is that they have students give
the graduation speeches because the
adults have heard it all before
and so they won't say it because that
sounds trite to them but it doesn't
sound trite to us because we are new
we're young we're ready we're fresh
fresh and so clean and doesn't say exact
words and the sky on Mars is red you
might think that the cameras on Mars can
tell you what that sky color is but s
town is the best Podesta John has ever
heard his children's puke is a yellowy
color and he hates oral surgery and
about I mean did you have a colonoscopy
between this question and the previous
question yeah I mean basically that so I
think Tess I think Hank started out on
the right track with I know at times the
world seems more malevolent than benign
but I think that after you say that you
should just say and you know it probably
is more slightly more malevolent than
benign and then I think you should just
sit down i'm tired a'these hopeful
optimistic graduation speeches that
everything's gonna be okay no it's not
no I mean it's like you know the best
that the best years of your life are
ahead of you Tess and I always think a
good graduation speech is one that
acknowledges that high school was not
like merely awesome you know like I
always disliked the graduation speeches
where they would be like and won't we
have wonderful memories of prom like
maybe maybe well some of us will have
good memories of from others of us will
have terrible memories of prom and
furthermore like I feel like if you're
doing it right like high school isn't
the best you know like hopefully the
roller coaster at some point will reach
like a high
piqué than it did at prom that's what I
think about the life in American high
schools I think it's very easy to
romanticize it and we have a strong
culture of romanticizing it that many
would tell you I have participated and
despite my best attempts not to and it's
gonna be you know like it gets harder
but it also gets more interesting from
there don't you think oh I definitely do
John I had a mix of high school
experiences but the first few years were
real bad so yes yeah yeah I also I also
had kind of like two high school
experiences of which the first was the
worst and the second was better and also
I would say pretty good but I don't look
back on that time as like the happiest
time of my life or anything I look back
on it as like a really complicated oh
yeah I know like pretty much every other
time I know I've had a few years in my
life that were pretty great like that I
could look back too and I think well
that was a pretty great year but most of
the years in my life have been
complicated
well speaking speaking of which John I
have to tell you we got to hit our
sponsors for the day this podcast
brought to you by terrible memories from
prom terrible memories from prom yeah
probably I don't know I by the way I
went to like three different proms and I
had three different but all really
interesting cool experiences today's
podcast also brought to you by s town s
town it's so much better than this
podcast podcast is also brought to you
by the Quail Antwerp Belgian Bantam a
chicken I think oh it is a chicken yeah
no it's a chicken but it's most
important and famous human
representative is Lauren and lastly
today's podcast is brought to you by
that minivan on Mars that minivan on
Mars not great at setting the white
balance apparently it's just complicated
okay it's complicated how our eyes work
I believe you I just think it's a little
stupid that we don't know what color the
I I believe you you're a much smarter
person than I am I'm sure that you're
right let's answer one more question
Hank from our listeners by the way sorry
for all the questions we didn't get to I
feel very bad all right I think we got a
question here from Bastian who writes
Dear John and Hank recent events have
made me extremely paranoid about the
news I'm consuming there seems to be so
much misinformation going around really
you think that I feel the need to
scientifically fact check everything I
read before share my family but I simply
don't have the time for that how much
fact-checking and cross-referencing do
you do before you share what's happening
in the world and when do you feel
confident to share and engage in any
discussion some dubious advice would be
appreciated greetings from Germany no
Bastian nah is there any way you can
send Angela Merkel over here and now I
don't mean for a visit I mean for good
we th D in physical chemistry to lead
our country we've got Justin Trudeau
right there he's right there you could
just come I don't believe Justin Trudeau
even went to graduate school it's true
yeah Merkel has a lot going for Bastion
here's what I gotta say like if you're
looking at a tweet if you're looking at
some like thing that got like sent to
you through social media
you got a fact check that stuff it's
just yeah but if you're looking at an
article that's published by a reputable
news organization that is actually about
the news rather than about hot takes
about the news or about whether or not
what someone said was true or not then
you're safe and so what would generally
are talking about fact-checking
everything before you send along is
whether like is is like the discussion
of controversy and scandals which to me
is seeming less and less like news and
more and more like entertainment and and
so like yes it's almost as if it doesn't
really matter whether that fact is true
before you that's not really so much
what you should think about before you
send it on though do do that but whether
or not that fact is actually helping
people understand the world better or
it's just making them feel a way that
they enjoy which tends to be a way that
in which they are belittling the people
that they dislike
I think it's also a question of like is
this closer to information that is being
you know like carefully reported and
vetted which I will say I think right
now large media companies do a better
job of than internet lone wolves
including by the way Hank and John Green
or as I prefer to think of them John and
Hank green I also I I also think that
you have to consider is this closer in
content to information about the ongoing
famine in Somalia or is this closer in
content to information about Kim
Kardashian's marriage to Kanye West
because I actually think both of those
are important and I understand why
people want to be informed about them
both but I think the level of
fact-checking that you have to do for
one is different than the level of
fact-checking you have to do for the
other because I just think that yeah
it's like you said Hank we are sharing a
lot of what we're sharing is not really
about the news it's really about yeah
trying to find out who we identify with
and trying to establish who we are which
is important it's just not it's just not
news there's a there's a certain amount
of like what I think then the news has
become and I think this is not it's like
a immediately new thing but a lot of it
is about like like okay we need to try
and convince a group like a larger group
of people to be on the right I'm using
air quotes side of this conversation and
and so the the the things that we choose
to share are the things that influence
like what you're like that have a higher
chance of influencing someone's opinion
rather than just what is the most
newsworthy event of the day because and
I totally get that because when I'm
sharing stuff in the internet I mostly
want to share stuff that's like look we
need to make better decisions and we
need to make we need to have more people
who agree that these are the things that
are import
and that those things that we don't
think are important aren't important and
so it's almost like we should like there
is a much bigger part of what News has
become now that's about that's just
purely about politics rather than about
being informed about something and when
the world is as complicated as it is
being informed is very difficult and
it's much easier to sort of have a
worldview and then just accept whatever
content fits within that worldview and
share that content but I think that it
is really started to serve us very
poorly by the way this is something that
hick and I both struggle with like we
are not the we are oh yeah I do this all
the time you're not the wise or the man
trying to tell you about the world we
are the we are with you we are in this
we are the problem you're the problem
yeah it's something that we struggle
with a lot in the interest of
fact-checking though Hank I just want to
note that Justin Trudeau started a
master's degree in environmental
geography but then gave it up and sought
public office and now is of course the
Prime Minister of Canada one of his
principal advisors is named Gerald bunk
[Laughter]
that's not super relevant but it's just
another thing you have to stay informed
on the funny names that that Prime
Minister's advisers have you really I
feel like you let me down you let me
down on the chicken facts did you did
you just like run out of chicken facts
job no I wanted to move I wanted to move
on to the Gerald Butz issue which I feel
like is one of those things that we're
ignoring because we're only paying
attention to news about like the current
political scandal in the United States
rather than paying attention to the news
of who is the fourteenth most powerful
Canadian according to a Maclean's
magazine piece in 2014
Gerald Butz is the 14th most powerful
Canadian all right Hank it's time for
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I'm
gonna start off with news from AFC
Wimbledon because
we lost to nil to Port Vale hmm in in in
Ligue 1 the Ligue 1 season is wrapping
up and I wouldn't say that AFC Wimbledon
is is firing on all cylinders at the
moment however we won arguably our most
important game of the second half of the
season against the franchise currently
applying its trade in Milton Keynes and
41 games into the season with five games
to go we are sitting on 54 points which
in the world of Ligue 1 is known as
enough that is enough points to stay up
so yeah so I don't know that we're
really we really have much to play for
at the moment except for pride of course
Bry is very important but not important
enough to beat port male well congrats
on the enough John what else can we ask
for in life then enough that's right no
listen if AFC Wimbledon finish 12th in
week one after getting promoted last
season I am delighted that's great news
what's the news from Mars oh well
there's a bit of a bit of a spat John I
you know you don't you don't know
necessarily that there's drama in the
Mars world because well I mean we can't
have long debates about what what color
the sky is but indeed so you you know
Elon Musk and you know Neil deGrasse
Tyson and I actually I actually
literally know both of them I have met
both what when did you meet you ah musk
yeah I have I have not to brag but like
I've texted with Elon Musk
you are totally first of all bragging
second of all lying right no I'm not
lying
what do you have a spell he came up to
me at a party and he said that he really
liked my who said it Charlie Sheen or
Muammar Gaddafi video oh my goodness
gracious why don't I know this I don't
know I can't believe I've never told you
that before anyway yes I have met both
Neil deGrasse Tyson and and Elon Musk
are they in are they in in a in a war
now they are honest they're in a minimum
of spat maximum Oh is there any way that
I could be brought in to mediate cuz I'm
ready yeah valid yes I definitely got
definitely gonna sit on that stage at
the at space con the space kind of thing
space conjugating anyway
neil degrasse tyson oh my god just what
we need Hank with another business idea
neil degrasse tyson was doing a reddit
AMA and was asked if he would take take
Elon Musk's SpaceX trip to Mars and he
he said he had a condition which what he
said quote I really like Earth so any
space trip I take I take I'm
double-checking that there's sufficient
funds for me to return also I'm not
taking that trip until Elon Musk sends
his mother and brings her back alive
then I'm good for it me I mean I think
that's I think that's perfectly charming
I think that it's I think it's charming
but I think it's a little unfair maybe
not mom maybe somebody who's a little
bit like more physically fit than Elon
Musk's probably quite aging mother I
mean yeah you on musk as a brother
so maybe yeah but I I'm just saying like
in general I get the III I don't know
III get his point I am also a huge fan
of Earth so maybe I'm a little bit a
little bit biased here by the way Elon
Musk's mother is not that old
no she's also gorgeous she is rather
gorgeous she's a South African Canadian
model and dietitian according according
to Wikipedia and she was born in 1948 so
she could still go to Mars oh yeah she
could totally go to Mars she looks like
she may have been there already this
picture is amazing
ya know she definitely photographs
amazingly yeah yeah well you know I
think we can't all be Elon Musk and we
can't all be Elon Musk's mother what
else did we learn today
oh we learned that John knows Elon Musk
and he didn't tell me it's true how the
whole thing it's true we learned the
chicken sperm can survive for more than
a month inside of a chicken and we
learned that chickens in China outnumber
chickens in America one of the greatest
national concern confer Chitty Chitty
tickety-tack what happened to me don't
know it was like it's like you're a
robot that broke down I've long
suspected that you might be an
artificial intelligence
yeah yeah vers it see we're a child and
thought that everybody was fake except
you I did I did think that when I was a
child and by the way I have never heard
a particularly compelling argument about
why I was wrong like I now believe that
I was wrong and that every other human
is also a human but just to be clear I
believe that because I think it makes me
a better person not because I think that
it is provably true and lastly we
learned that the podcast as town is
truly fantastic you should listen to it
right away
ok ok well I'm worried because I heard
the hot take that it shouldn't exist so
now I'm worried that you're wrong I mean
you know what maybe that's right I and
and like I've missed something terrible
and I'm promoting some horrific podcast
that I'm gonna get a lot of a lot of
flashback but IIIi enjoyed it very much
and as someone who has lived at times in
small town Alabama not too far from
where this podcast is set I found it
fascinating and and quite compelling ah
Hank thank you for podcasting with me it
is now our job to go and do this week in
Ryan's which is available this week in
riot it's available to anybody out there
who wants to go to our patreon at
patreon.com slash and dear Hank and John
you get a little mini podcast every week
and yeah I think it's gonna be I think
it's gonna be a good thing but you don't
have to go it's not that good but thanks
for bonding with me thanks everybody for
listening you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com thank you undo the
credits dear Hank and John is produced
by rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan
Gibson our editor is Nicholas Jenkins
Victoria Ben Sira now is our head of
community and communications and our
music is by the great gunnarolla as they
say in our hometown don't forget be a
awesome
[Music]